so my question is as an actor is it more
challenging to tell a story in less time
no no I do the best I can with the time
I have and I think that's what all
actors do we we make do my preference is
to have as much time as possible because
i want to know as much as I can about
about the character about what's going
on if I'm doing a piece this long which
is roughly ten minutes hmm I still have
to know as much about the character it
is much about about the part as much
about my intentions as if I were doing a
larger piece and if I have only one or
two scenes in a picture which happens
often uh I still have to be a full
person sure I still have to know stuff
sure and I do my best to do that you
know la fortuna is based on this made
december relationship that you have with
with Dorothy your character James it
seems like both characters are kind of
dissatisfied with the arrangement but
maybe a little reluctant or unwilling to
discuss it or address it so it seems
like your story relies a lot on subtext
and i love that great shot of the bug
floating in the water on his back
completely helpless well Sorrentino laid
it out for me yeah pretty much obviously
James is a once powerful guy mm-hmm he's
a builder he's an architect look at the
house he lives in and he's now at the
point where he dresses in a way that he
wouldn't want to dress he eats the way
he doesn't want to eat he doesn't smoke
but he wants to smoke and all of these
things are because of this wife who
loves him but he's drowning he's
drowning and it's fascinating the way to
me the way Sorrentino wrote this all the
words are his we had some some sure
discussion about the script one or two
words I thought might be different but
he wrote it beautifully and he at first
he said whatever you want to do is find
ultimately he wanted his words and I was
thrilled with that because that's the
way I like to work anyway I had two
directors by the way okay you will
notice if you read in IMDb you'll see
all the writers and all the directors
and you will see in parenthesis after
one of the writers filippi Barbosa and
it says transitions and one of the
directors Vicente amor him and it says
transitions and the object was I think
well I guess I'm not sure how it worked
i think it worked for us but but i don't
know how it worked for the others and i
can't tell you which ones filippi
Barbosa wrote in which ones Vicente
amorim directed a Barbosa did write one
scene in our piece and Vicente amorim
directed that piece and which piece was
that the airplane ah yeah did she did
look like she really laid one on you she
slapped you that hard he led many on me
yeah we we shot it a lot of times I told
her to do that um I didn't realize how
strong she was but you soon found out
yeah we managed to sleep through it
though convincing yeah so well done she
was a joy to work with by the way the
only Mortimer's a fabulous actress and
wonderful to work well let's talk about
Emily how did you how did you establish
the relationship of your characters with
Emily did you guys have a lot of time to
prepare did you were no rehearsal no
rehearsal no rehearsal just uh first
time first time we ran through the scene
actually was by the pool by the swing
pool okay and I got about ten words out
of my first line and Sorrentino says no
so so I had to go to my second choice
okay and after that I really got no
direction from him he seemed happy at
one point he said you could take more
time but that's nice I knew that he was
happy though with what I did even though
he didn't say so because we had a lot of
nice dinners and he never seemed to over
drink so I thought he was pleased well
that's a good sign how did this role
come to you let's back up to how did
this all start by the grace of God I got
a phone call from my manager Brad lemac
one day he said do you know an Italian
director named paolo sorrentino said no
he said well he knows you and he's
shooting a film in rio de janeiro and
they want to make an offer and that was
it we shot this in October of 2013 Wow
how many days did you shoot we shot a
little over a week we were there for a
couple of weeks okay in November of 2013
paolo sorrentino's filmed the great
beauty one the best picture award at the
European Film Awards and in
january-february in March it ran the
table mm-hmm it got the BAFTA Award for
Best Foreign Language picture it got the
golden globes and got the Oscar um did
you fall in love with Rio I like trio a
lot there are two Rios there's there's a
real that is a dangerous and in abject
poverty and there's a real on the beach
and it's just beautiful our hotel was
the fasano on de panama beach next to
copacabana beach we shot on a beach
called groom re mm-hmm and it was it was
a great experience I got to meet one of
the other directors Oh Jer mo arriaga
directed the taxing the fighting uh-huh
he's intense isn't he yeah well then
that that was certainly enjoy but he had
written babble and he'd written 21 grams
and I got to have breakfast
with yermo several times because it
seems like he and I were the only ones
up that early so we shared we shared
breakfast a couple of times and he asked
me if I'd ever worked in Mexico I said
that I had shot a commercial once in
Mexico he said you should do a movie in
Mexico and I said well Guillermo the
ball is in your court yeah so you feel
like the obvious sounds like certainly
the locations influence not only you but
everybody that was working on the
picture I mean that's oh I i hope i hope
so I think chili on the same time we all
we had a great time I was amazed at how
well everybody speaks English yeah I've
taught a in Lebanon mm-hmm several times
yes and when I was teaching in Lebanon I
mentioned to the kids because they all
speak several languages you know that
they all speak they speak English fairly
well hmm they all speak Arabic and
French if they're armenian they also
speak our meeting some of them speak
Italian so I asked him if they knew what
the English terms were for those four
people who speak multiple languages they
said they didn't know and I said it's
called multilingual is what we call it
and I said if you only speak two
languages you know what that would be
they said no I said that's bilingual and
he said there's also an expression for
people who only speak one language they
said what is that I said we call that
person on American and we're lucky if we
speak English very well yeah exactly and
you said Emily was concerned about her
accent yeah she was she was she was very
concerned her English was famine her
American was fabulous yeah and she kept
asking me is it okay is it okay to I
sound American I said yeah I'm gonna
learn from you yeah she was amazing yeah
she was crazed really terrific terrific
to work well it looks like you guys had
great rapport even though of course
you're playing this yeah I think we did
change we were at the airport waiting
for our plane both of the planes we had
quite a wait she was flying to new york
and i was flying back to LA and I had
given my acting book to de pollo hmm and
I had also given one to Guillermo
arriaga
and we were at the airport she said why
didn't you give me your acting book I
said because I thought you'd be offended
she said no I want your acting book so I
signed a book for oh that's nice but but
I'm scared ever offer my acting book to
an actor Holy Smoke you shouldn't be
yeah make him write a book report but it
was Yeah right but Emily was fabulous
though and and I thought that was sweet
of her she was very complimentary to me
she uh she sent me a lovely email after
oh that's nice said something
outrageously complimentary to me well
good think that I hope so thank you
thank you guys so much thank you